the secret sauce of Amazon with their
several principles at Amazon but the
number one thing that has made us
successful by far is you're gonna work
with the problems that the company needs
you to work on not the clones you want
to work on I like to go up to people as
thanks and I say I'm always trying to
get people off autopilot wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey Sara Carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you two you've got
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believed
life and learn the secret sauce behind
some of the world's most successful
entrepreneurs
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one have a high pain threshold
with Elon Musk
when does have to be focused on the
short term and money coming in when
creating a company because otherwise the
company will die so that I think that a
lot of times people think like creating
company is gonna be fun I would say it's
not it's really not that fun I mean
there are periods of fun and there are
periods of where it's just awful and
particularly if you a CEO of the company
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in the company
there's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right so you
only spend on things on your time on
things that are going wrong and and
there are things that are going wrong
that other people can't can't take care
of so you're like the worst you have a
filter for the crappiest problems in the
company the most pernicious and painful
problem so I wouldn't say it's it's I
think you have to feel quite compelled
to do it and have a fairly high pain
threshold and there's a friend of mine
who says like starting companies like
staring at the abyss and any
glass and there's some truth to that
we're staring into the abyss part is
that you're going to be constantly
facing the extermination of the company
because most most startups fail that's
like 90% probably 99% of Starks fail so
I so you that that's the staring into
the abyss part you can't constantly
saying okay this if I don't get this
right the company will die it should be
quite stressful
quite stressful and and then the eating
glass part is you've got you've got to
do you've got to do the problems you're
gonna start you're gonna work in the
problems that the company needs you to
work on not the problems you want to
work on and so that the that's you and
I've working on problems that that you'd
really wish you weren't working on okay
so that's the eating glass part then
that goes on for a long time so how do
you keep your focus on the big picture
when you're constantly faced with we
could be out of business in a month well
it's just a very small percentage of
mental energies on the on the big
picture like you know you know you know
where you generally heading for and and
the fascial path is gonna be some sort
of zig zaggy thing in that direction and
try not to deviate too far from the path
that that you want to be on but you're
gonna have to do that some degree but I
don't want to I don't want to diminish
the I mean I think the product the
profit motive is it is a is a good one
if the rules of an industry are properly
set up so there's something
fundamentally wrong with profit in fact
profit just means that people are paying
you more for the that whatever you're
doing then you're spending to create it
that's a good thing and if you're not if
that's not the case then you'll be out
of business and rightfully so sure
you're not adding enough value lesson
number two focus on your customers with
Jeff Bezos
the secret sauce of Amazon where there
several principles at Amazon but the
number one thing that has made us
successful by far is
obsessive-compulsive focus on the
customer
opposed to obsession over the competitor
and I talk so often to other CEOs and
some other CEOs and also founders and
entrepreneurs and I can tell that even
though they're talking about customers
they're really focusing on competitors
and it is a huge advantage to any
company if you can stay focused on your
customer instead of your competitors
also if you want to have more confidence
and self-love check out my 254 series
that's free the link to join is in the
description below there are times when
if something is important enough
you've leave it enough that you do you
do it in spite of fear if everything has
to work in two to three years then that
limits what you can do when I was
selling copiers door-to-door I had a
very clear vision of what my life was
gonna be like lesson number three create
change with Mark Zuckerberg to me
entrepreneurship is about creating
change not just creating companies and
you know the most effective
entrepreneurs that who I've met it care
deeply about some mission and some
change that they're trying to create and
often they don't even start because
they're trying to create a company right
in you know that's how I think about you
know my connection to tell all of us
here is you know I was getting started I
am and I want it I care deeply about
giving everyone a voice right and giving
people the tools to share everything
that they cared about and bring a
community together and you know it
started small and in one university and
I didn't think it was gonna be a company
at the time as a matter of fact I was
pretty convinced that at some point
someone would build something like this
for the world but you know I thought
that that would be some other company
that you know already had thousands of
Engineers and was used to building stuff
for hundreds of millions of people
around the world and you know what ended
up happening was you know that no one
built it right so we just kind of kept
on going right I mean people said it
each step along the way you know what
you're doing alright maybe college
students like it but no one else is
gonna like it and you know there's not
gonna be any money in doing this so
alright so you only really do it if you
care alright if you're passionate about
doing
and then it started growing and people
said it would be a fad and it would
never be a good business but you know
you keep going because you care not
because you're trying to create a
business and you know then there's the
shift in mobile where people thought
that you know it wouldn't be a
sustainable business and you know it
through each of these things you the
entrepreneurs who I think build things
that last for a long time keep going
because they care fundamentally about
the change that they're trying to create
in the world and they're not in it just
to build a company lesson number four go
off the autopilot but Sara Blakely one
of the things I also do is I like to go
up to people it's thanks than I say I'm
always trying to get people off
autopilot like if you think about it
everything we do almost everything we do
in life is autopilot we're doing things
exactly the way someone else showed us
how to do it or taught us how to do it
well if you're doing things exactly the
way everyone else is there's no there's
not going to be any real significant
change there's not going to be a really
meaningful potential breakthrough so I
always go up to people at sinks and say
if nobody showed you how to do your job
how would you be doing it and I'll say
just sit with that you know I'm always
like I'll stop myself often and just say
okay you know this is how I've been
doing it but is this right and give
yourself the time to think about it so I
ask people to do that unless the number
five the last one before a very special
bonus clip is focus on passion with
Warren Buffett the question is about the
personal qualities we look for and the
executives we place at our various
companies the first thing is we don't
usually play something I mean they come
with them we don't have anybody to place
so I have the problem occasionally if
somebody dies or to replace a CEO but
most of our CEOs came with the deal
Clayton Homes which were even we're
buying comes with Kevin Clayton right
running it we will put no one in there
he will run the place just as before but
in terms of the personal closet when a
when a seller comes to me with a
business whether it's Clayton or any
others and the others I'd Friedman at
Borsheims mrs. B at Nebraska Furniture
Mart when they come to me
the first question I have to ask myself
because I'm counting on them to run the
place I have to decide what do they love
the money or do they love the business
now there's nothing wrong with liking
the money I mean the only like money but
but they've kind of loved the business
they kind of have a passion for it
because if I give them a whole bunch of
money and they love the money and they
don't love the business no matter what
they tell me six months from now they'll
be gone you know I mean just all of a
sudden say why am I getting up at 7:00
in the morning just so I can send a lot
of money to Omaha you know I mean it it
just it won't work so they have to love
the business I mean I want people with a
passion for the business I used to say
that I had a one line employment for me
one question employment form the
question was are you a fanatic you know
if you answered yes you got the job
because I want somebody's fanatical
about their business now have a special
bonus tip from Oprah Winfrey on how to
surround yourself with great people that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking an action
here we go
question number one what's the passion
that you need to focus on number two
where do you need to get off the
autopilot and number three how can you
better focus on your customers this week
and if you like this video and promise
you take action after watching it give
me a hash tag believe down in the
comments as well we don't just watch
videos here we do something about it
so give me a hash tag believe make that
promise to yourself and then get to work
people don't always like you and they're
not always happy for you and if you
surround yourself with people who are
not accustom to your success they become
fearful
they become scared because you are
reflecting back something to them but
they don't recognize now they're not
going to say you know I'm very fearful
because you're reflecting back to me
something I don't recognize they're
going to say you know what they're gonna
say they don't say who she thinks she is
who she thinks she is that only happens
when you were around people who do not
mean and want and aspire to the best for
you people who want the best for you
want you to be your best so my greatest
advice to you is to surround yourself
with people who are going to fill your
cup until your cup runneth over
so when people say you're so full of
yourself you can say yeah yes I'm full
I'm so full my cup runneth over
and to know that once your cup runneth
over you cannot spend your life with
your gallon-sized offerings offering
them to pint-sized people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you have got to surround yourself with
gallon-sized people who can hang in the
same company with you so that you're not
offering your Gallants to those little
pikes out there who can't hold it anyway
if you want to know why poverty is not
an accident and what keeps you broke I
think you'll enjoy the video right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there
so thing about - a suffering people
crinch people that do it that's the one
word whenever I post about it people
cringe